heavy machinery works to lift the
mangled wreckage of the two trains
and cut a path to rescue survivors crews
toil in the blazing summer heat
offering any support they can to those
still trapped
but it took hours for the equipment to
get to dahaki
in a remote part of pakistan sindh
province where fields turned into
makeshift hospitals
and bodies were lined up on the soil
you can see that the rescue operation is
going on soldiers from the military
rangers district administration
personnel and health teams are taking
part
the accident happened after the coaches
of a northbound train derailed
and fell across the opposite track a
packed southbound train
plowed into them the driver of that
train told local media
he'd seen the derailed cars and tried to
brake but
the train that was going towards punjab
collapsed and the train called cersei
that was coming from punjab collided
with it
seven to eight rail carriages were
destroyed many passengers are still
trapped
huge crowds of people gathered around
the carnage some climbing on top to
reach survivors and bodies
dozens of people were taken to hospital
many in a critical condition
prime minister imran khan says he's
shocked by the accident and promised a
full inquiry into what happened
so far authorities haven't ruled
anything out including sabotage
but rail accidents are common in
pakistan where the network's seen
decades of decline
blamed on corruption mismanagement and a
lack of investment
at least 75 people died when a train
caught fire while traveling from karachi
to raul pindi two years ago
while 19 people died in 2016 when a
passenger train crashed into another
the information ministers tweeted he has
a plan for a revamped rail system
and that it's a priority for the
government alexia o'brien al jazeera
and al jazeera's kamal haider has muna
from islamabad
this is a remote region it's very dry
it speaks summer and the fact that it is
a difficult
job when you're removing such heavy
equipment as rail carriages
uh of course uh the first uh tragedy
that happened was the fact
that this was a remote region and it
took several
precious hours for the rescue teams
including
the heavy lift equipment to reach the
spot
and even now we are told that the rescue
mission is still
underway the search of course is for
those
who may be trapped under the wreckage or
may be trapped inside the wreckage
because this is going to be a difficult
task but the majority of the people have
been taken away
those that have been injured to local
hospitals this is a remote region
even in the best of times medical
facilities there are not good
and therefore the likelihood that we may
see the death toll rising
even higher